gang if you're watching this or
listening to this episode the date comes
out on monday the special drops tomorrow
december 21st
2021 it drops and we need the entire
army of garbage to help spread the word
so if you're not subscribed to the
podcast subscribe right now on youtube
tell everybody your grandmother your
grandfather sisters brothers cousins
ex-girlfriends i don't give a [ __ ] just
make sure you juice the numbers baby we
need it
we love you bye
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r.u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find that if they grew up to be classy
yeah or if they're just a big old piece
of trash i'm your host stage foley
coming at you on a beautiful day down
here in auntie's basement she's upstairs
a little upset yeah toys for tots
she went out she bought a toy she went
to the local bar thought she was gonna
get a tater tot appetizer for free but
that's not how it [ __ ] works okay my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me
he is the ceo of ru garbage brand new
country album out right now number one
on the [ __ ] charts give it up for
kevin james ryan kj
hey what's up gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are true [ __ ] cooking baby and then
it's the holiday season if you if you
got an extra couple of bucks laying
around you want to send a gift pass to
somebody send it to patreon.com
ru garbage baby you can sign up you get
a bunch of bonus content ayg hard
feelings live streams the whole nine
yards do it merry christmas and happy
holidays jack conte and sam yam and both
of their beautiful wonderful families
they're amazing people stanford grads
those two smart kids smart kids we love
them a couple of eggheads
that's the way we like it baby how about
a nice quick shout out speaking of
egghead to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man makes us all look good
didn't appreciate the egghead comment
you can't see him give it up for t-bone
mcmuffin toby mcmullen what's up dudes
what's up good to see you buddy very
very very excited to have our incredibly
special guest here with us for the first
time today from the coast listen
yeah
[Laughter]
this young man is a very successful very
funny stand-up comedian actor and
podcaster get a load of these [ __ ]
credits right here because we got a
little star power in his dump
let's start out here human giant
according to jim two broke girls
workaholics the heat rick and morty real
house husbands of hollywood spy
silicon valley ghostbusters mad tv
curb your enthusiasm baller second act
arrested development robot chicken the
bellman power young rock american dad
hacks loved that show late night with
greg ferguson gotham comedy live chelsea
lately at midnight the church of what's
happening now tiger belly lights out
with david spade and of course he is the
host of the amazing podcast about last
night but the big question about his
mind today is he garbage he's out here
doing a corporate gig from hollywood
he shows up
good looking kid put together
brings his own burrito
with him byob baby
that's la if i ever seen it he brought
yeah he had that on a plane that was a
carry-on burrito he couldn't be more
hollywood if he was splitting that with
paris hilton ladies and gentlemen give
it up for the one the only mr adam ray
hey thanks fellas yeah the kid's here i
thought about not bringing the burrito
and i thought it was like where'd you
can be a nice topic of conversation just
a spot uh i have to fish through my uber
eats but just a random i am a burrito on
the plane guy though is that a weird wow
my god these la types
i mean i'm just a big burrito guy my
buddy where will you get the burrito in
the airport oh yeah and then just roll
on i mean that's a risky move you're
bringing it from
a ziploc bag
i've seen that by the way getting it
through security dude i've seen people i
mean and i have gotten uh accosted for
like some of my eats and treats on the
plane i had a british one in front of me
once it's turn around and i open i had a
sandwich i don't know if it was tuna but
it definitely stopped it wasn't tuna
and so uh and so somebody crack a window
dude so i start to take a bite and she
turns around and i have my headphones on
and i see her just through the crack of
the seats just turning around kind of
looking just like staring at me so i can
feel her staring so i'm like now it's
just on me to decide when to look up and
lock eyes with sure so i see her looking
and i know she's definitely pissed so i
took a little bit more time i kind of
like peeled things down and kind of i
even like just kind of for effect was
like
i knew she was watching me and i was
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] like i know you
don't like this this move right now but
i'm committing to it so i start to take
a bite and then i hear start talking and
i got the headphones on but i can still
see her and feel her energy so i kind of
then take off i go what's up and she
goes are you really gonna eat that
and i was like yeah i brought on the
plane i go and i got a second one in the
bag so uh saddle up you know it was
gonna be a long flight to tucson and
then and then she ding calls the guy
over and he comes over
and uh and i see her again headphones on
but i'm just watching all this from my
period and she's like uh you know
so then i see the guy just like oh all
right and then i see him like do that to
me so i go yo what's up he goes
you're killing me yeah yeah like but
he's got he doesn't want to have to like
call me over this he's like dude i'm
trying to [ __ ] make sure we don't
crash like there's other things
who's going to fly the plane they're
going to put your white light away
yeah yeah put your white fish away so
then he's just like
can he can
can you stop eating the sandwich i go
not only can i not stop eating it i got
a second one lined up right here
doubling down on his family
and he just goes he goes come on man i
go i don't know what to tell you man
like you know we both bought seeds and
he goes yeah did you just
turn this into some sort of sandwich
fiasco
and uh and i was like all right i was
like i'll take two more bites and put it
away cool and then the woman's like she
goes two more bites and the guy was like
two more bites and then i put it away in
the middle here yeah i mean in the
middle i'm trying to
yeah dude sorry i'm with the british
lady man that's right what are you doing
were you in first class or coach was
coach
that's a coach move that's a real coach
i was first class on the way here i was
able to get bumped up and so that's
where i feel like you know you do
whatever the [ __ ] you want but you have
korean barbecue up there what is
everything you got your own hibachi
what's going on we had every flavor of
dungaroos we had capri suns without the
straws they just squeeze it into your
mouth
holy [ __ ] what is the back story of mr
adam ray where did you grow up give us
the whole scoop totally i grew up in
lake forest park washington okay like a
real small suburb uh about 25 minutes
north of seattle and um nice uh upper
middle class nice or are we talking like
there's there's cobain's neighborhood i
mean every part of seattle has pockets
where it feels like you could go from
poor uh food stamps to like oh they got
a sports court you know
in the backyard so there was different
pockets uh i mean the house i grew up in
when my folks were together was
i guess pretty nice uh two-car garage
right big driveway all right plum tree
oh okay
we never put but it was just it was in a
nice neighborhood and then they split
and then we moved not too far from there
but again so with my mom and sis
that was um definitely like a downgrade
yeah okay uh where it was just like you
know um
it just was shittier and then after that
then my sister uh went to a girls school
it was just my mom and i and then even
shittier from that in a true like
i didn't want to have people over like i
remember the first time a girl came over
and i was like yeah we're just staying
here for the time
we're just laying low to the face
off yeah yeah i got drunk and burned
down our mansion
one of those it's like a um
it's basically a i guess tennis court
basketball that's basketball
oh okay there was one guy in our
neighborhood that had one and we would
like drive and look at it like as a
family oh yeah
it's a hot commodity i hear they're
playing oh those are the families that
gave out king-sized candy bars
[ __ ] yeah it was almost like do you
remember when like fisher price or
whoever had the three-in-one like pool
table [ __ ] yahtzee board and [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah it was some sort of
three-in-one ping-pong skee-ball yeah
billiards they had one in the basement
you did yeah the thunder dome oh my gosh
that was the game that was the basement
five dollar cover charger ladies drink
for free that was the safe word when
your friends came down
holy [ __ ] where did your where's your
dad go from there so my dad so so then
they uh they split and how old are you
when this happens uh maybe eight and a
half nine okay and so uh sister's older
younger sister's two years older and now
for me i was like all right we get two i
get two houses now that's a lot how i
viewed it so you saw the house until i
saw the house and then went to my dads
and saw where they were staying which
was also kind of a [ __ ] but not too
far um and then you know my stepmom was
filipino and so there's a lot of kimchi
around and i was like i don't what the
what the [ __ ] is that and then she would
make fun of me for smuggling doritos
under the couch because i was uh
you know just i love snacks and so um so
then uh went back home
mom and i were just chilling for a while
um wait so when they got to divorce you
went and lived with your dad with my mom
every other weekend with the dad yeah
okay every weekend both were kind of
like um how quick did he get remarried
pretty quick okay that's why they split
yeah gotcha and so um say no more having
a stepmom is a weird thing it's like
i've always said this it's like
like if when if someone brings like
crystal clear pepsi to thanksgiving
you're like all right nobody wanted this
but we'll take a couple sips because dad
brought it let's be respectful yeah um
and uh
but uh it got real quiet does everyone
here oh yeah yeah i i haven't strike a
chord no i have one and you took me back
to like 93.
that you made
yeah this guy seems all right
[Laughter]
yeah my mom dated some [ __ ] winners
too for a minute there i mean really
there was this one guy who
who uh came over and it was just such a
weird thing to try to
you know uh i mean we were just truly
like running on uh on empty like i mean
it was like a lot of tv dinner type
situations a lot of like
soups spaghettios right just your your
uh whatever to get by so it got tough
after the afternoon yeah for sure and i
don't even remember it being that
glamorous pre uh single mom i think like
spaghettios were still in the mix with
two packs
so [ __ ] what the [ __ ] dad spaghetti
spaghettios used to have meatballs in it
yeah
it's a good serving of protein yeah we
went from spaghettios to beefaroni when
dad left
and so um
she had this guy come over once
and you know just when you're trying to
impress the kid
you're just going for uh yeah going for
gold and so like he came out i'm
shooting hoops uh you know we'd finally
gotten a
basketball hoop put in which was it
installed or was it the movable one on
wheels no it was uh stuck into the con
which was a big deal i remember every
for honestly over a year you know it
just took so long and when i would come
back from my dad's and you would drive
down the hill and you could see our
place it was on the corner in this
cul-de-sac so every time we go on the
hill and you know i had no way to know
if it was put up yet and i'd always come
around the corner see if it was up and
it was like oh it's going to be this
weekend and it just wasn't just you know
put off and put off and uh you know
that's part of being a product of
divorce just constant disappointment
you're like is there a hoop up does it
at least salvage some sort of happiness
i know no maybe another 20 years who was
doing who put it who eventually put her
i put it up a friend of my mom's who
probably was [ __ ] i don't know so
this guy comes over and he comes out and
i'm shooting noobs he's like hey do you
mind if i shoot some basket shots with
you and right away i'm just like what
the [ __ ] did you just say
in passing oh and so he comes out they
were i think gonna go there he took me
to a manners game nolan ryan's last uh
game actually he retired in the first
inning after he gave up a grand slam
which was kind of exciting but but the
guy just looked weird and it's so weird
even at that age that you're assessing
like the attractiveness of a guy that's
with your mom like sure just the fact
that it was a new guy was kind of uh
was it was uh you know uh just tough to
kind of grasp yeah it's a lot to wrap
your head around but i'm like mom at
least you can [ __ ] like yeah this
guy's a three what are you doing dad
let's go
so he goes we do some basket shots and
then he comes out and then i pass him
the ball and he shoots it underhand ah
i'll never forget that and i remember
being like dude i remember an old school
gym teacher well at least you know
there's a good chance you probably
didn't close with your mom yeah well
dude those are his moves if that's your
move i'm like dude yeah it's like to
[ __ ] finger here he like goes uh like
he had her leg around her [ __ ] he's
like yeah we can call this the
ventriloquist olympic larry over here
yeah this guy take a hike at tacoma yeah
he got he got friend zoned real quick
that guy i hope you shoot underhand
that's a tough look yeah he was that was
a a pretty he was not maybe two or three
more dates after they took me to taco
time i remember that which was like
seattle's taco bell got me some seattle
super sonic trading cards again just
trying to buy my love yeah but you know
which is that's half the battle when
you're trying to impress uh you gotta
keep the kid entertained did you start
getting wise to this and start maybe
using this to your advantage when the
when the next couple bozos came around i
should have the next guy was like a
glass blower and then there was um
and then your mom knows how to pick it
and then there was a guy that just was
like hey i brought you a saxophone and
it was like already wet like a saxophone
but now she crushed him my stepdad
george shout out to him he's uh nice
he's a home run hero she's remarried
your dad's remarried yeah remarried um
but lake forest park again had a nice
uh a good mix um but again like there's
just different i was on the lower end of
things where it was like
you know i bought a lot of clothes from
value village you know what that is i
can imagine yeah i can put two and two
together i don't think it's nordstroms
there's no mob smashing the place to do
a smash and grab job i would assume yeah
yeah there's no tommy hilfiger
yeah that's so funny that i just asked
you at value village sounds like yeah
that's a high-end place adam i don't
know it's pretty weird there's a jamba
juice inside of it right yeah
no it's taco bell taco circle yeah it's
[ __ ] it's like if you can't get it at
goodwill you can probably find it at
valueville okay and so uh a lot of
clothes from there but but um you know
mom did a good job of you know working
what did she do three to five dollars so
she was three or five jobs oh yeah she
was cr i mean dude she was a um
activities coordinator at a senior
citizen home she was uh she had a lot of
assisted living which was helping um uh
uh placing families that had you know um
in um assisted living homes right like
the people who got you and go yeah uh
yeah
therapy family counseling kids
counseling i mean just just crushing it
so that i can at least like have a
basketball uniform and stuff like that
but nothing too crazy i mean didn't even
uh get a um you know uh
uh gaming system until i had my bar
mitzvah and got some cash and she was
like you can buy that [ __ ] for yourself
if you want i was like i will and then i
bought a sega saturn rolled the dice
damn that thing came and went so fast
yeah that was around for a hot weekend i
was the only one
i remember even to the store the guy was
like dude don't buy this and i was like
[ __ ] you neil and i was like you know
just it's my bar mitzvah money let me
spend it however i want but that game
came with like and it came you know the
system sucks
right 15 free games yeah
it was like so crazy striking out back
then jesus christ yeah it was it was a
it was a rough time but um humble
beginnings i like that
i mean yeah dude i mean just mom
instilled the uh the work ethic and um
and also you just go
i i think i and comedy i found because
you know i was a real big kid got teased
a lot and then i started to make buddies
laugh so then it was like okay cool i'm
not the fat kid i'm the funny kid yeah
and so then i just kind of
rode that train because it was like cool
that's truly just not it's taking
whatever the uh assaults that are coming
at me off the table yeah and now they're
coming to me for for goofs um and it
just you know came i mean probably for
all of us right just comes a little
you're not thinking of it as showing a
true skill set you're just like oh i'm
just i just think of something or i see
a moment to do something and i'm doing
it without really hesitating and also
yeah yeah totally um and also just
making people laugh like just you know
just felt good especially contrasting to
like you know getting the uh the
opposite
yeah or something yeah what was that or
a titty [ __ ] joke some of my friend's
dads would be like you have time for a
titty [ __ ]
that granola bar i was like i get it i
got a weight problem
yeah you [ __ ] dirtbag yeah
those dudes party what the [ __ ] my dad
left he's begging a filipino and the guy
my mom's sleeping with can't throw a
baseball three feet think i need your
[ __ ] right now
the [ __ ]
put on the a-team and beat it will you
uh what was the oh is the a-team with
you i love the 18
underrated series that's right george
prepared shout out to him um
[Laughter]
what what was the school your sister
went to uh it was i think it was called
cross creek is it private is it yeah so
did you board that school that paris
hilton dock it's she um pearson went to
a school similar to this where it was
yeah it was sent away she stole my mom's
van oh this was i was at my buddy's
house um
i'm sorry just why does your mother have
a van oh like a family van
it was a silhouette wait
she drove a uh
like a 16 passes she drove her maroon
station wagon for a while like from the
muppet movie and then um that's a band
and then my grandpa was like you got to
get a [ __ ] new car this thing's
falling apart so i think it was like
1200 bucks my mom swindled this guy or
[ __ ] bloom so we were at the um and
we got a deal and we drive home it
sounds like you blocked a lot of [ __ ]
yeah it was a uh uh it was like a space
fan we called it it was yeah
it had that round two of course yeah
yeah and uh and i was fired up from the
jetsons
yeah oh yeah every time we got him we
were like
and waiting for the wheels to fold up
dude it was awesome and uh and it was
just a new car right so that uh that
gets you jacked up so then we um
uh
she's sister was dating some guy and
just how old she at this point so i'm 13
i think she's 15. okay she's older and
uh and she's i was in eighth grade and
she my mom calls me she's like hey uh
can you see if uh kirk's mom can give
you a ride home i was like yeah why
what's up she's like uh your sister took
uh you're close um i think your money
probably that was in your uh your little
bank there um uh my money uh my purse my
bubba that's that and uh and the car and
i think she's going to arizona and i was
like
yeah i know so i'll get a ride home
i'll figure out dinner for myself too
yeah did she take the meatballs that
were frozen in the fridge is that
basketball net up by any chance i know
it's a bad time to ask but play a game
of knockout or something when we get
home
this podcast is sponsored by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals as you know me and
the big man are big proponents of uh
mental health and talking to somebody he
just started i've done it in the past
i i can't i can't speak more highly of
it and the good thing about better help
it will assess
your needs and match you with a licensed
professional therapist you'll be matched
with a therapist within under 48 hours
and it's not a crisis hotline it's not a
self-help line it's professional therapy
done securely online broad range of
expertise which might not be available
locally to you and the services
available uh for clients worldwide
so
a special offer for are you garbage
listeners you get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com
garbage one more time write it down take
charge of your life special offer for
are you garbage listeners get 10 off 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
garbage today do it
bespoke post bespoke post one more time
for the people in the cheap seats
bespoke post this winner upgrade your
daily routine with the bespoke post and
their new seasonal lineup of must-have
box of awesome collections guys as you
know i've said i've been saying it for
months it's cool guys [ __ ] you don't
know you need until you see you go oh i
gotta get me one of them bespoke pose
partners with small businesses and
emerging brands to bring in the most
unique goods every month they sent us i
they sent us a box i got a cool knife uh
big man and his wife got a cool hammock
i got a sweet duffle bag i take on a
road with me you gotta get involved with
these guys they know what they're doing
from winter cocktails to
cozy threads camping gear essentials box
of awesome has collections for every
part of your life to get started take
the quiz at box of awesome.com your
answers will help you pick the right box
of awesome for you they release new
boxes every month across a ton of
different categories it's free to sign
up you can skip a month or cancel at any
time each box only costs 45 bucks but
has over 70 dollars worth of gear inside
uh get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome.com
enter the code garbage at checkout
that's box of awesome.com promo code
garbage for 20
off your first box today do it
so wait a minute what why would you take
your clothes she uh for her boyfriend i
think yeah what by the way yeah and just
took everything and then got something
still together
no
now she's married to a right white
rapper named dirty and um yeah more on
that later let's put a pin in that yeah
how do you spell dirty d-i-r-t-a-y look
him up he just dropped a song called i'm
lost which is great because you're like
cool is there something right
uh so
holy hell hey dirty he wants the
sneakers back all right
oh that guy looks like he could [ __ ]
someone up though oh you find this guy
yeah baby holy hell never mind you look
great yeah
shout out to him i'm going to plug it
keep the van yeah
no so that's who she's with now okay so
he's uh that's a much better choice so
the guy she had in high school she's a
kid she's she's making mistakes got into
some uh shenanigans and and uh what was
in arizona uh a better life i don't know
dan marley you tell me man
better burritos you know i think it's
that's probably that was probably their
florida for us that's florida i'm
getting out of here i'm going to florida
oh man
i think she was going to glendale so my
dad lived there for a little bit and uh
she stayed there for a summer with him
and i think she just really got keen on
the spot and we uh
we were like okay [ __ ] and then they ran
out of gas in oregon
picked them up
and my grandparents were like
my mom's like i don't know what the [ __ ]
to do like this is just truly is this
her first big um got in trouble yeah i
mean that's a pretty she wouldn't come
around for a while you know friends come
over smoke and it wasn't like she was
doing [ __ ] crack and stuff like that
but just enough wear and tear and stress
my mom and so as a result i would like
you know i became a good kid i think as
definitely a result of that like i don't
think i was um some piece of [ __ ] anyway
but i i told the line i was like all
right i'm gonna [ __ ] clean the house
my mom is gone all day during the summer
so because i know she's already freaking
out that my sister won't be home for a
couple days and stuff like that good
morning
my grandma told me one point two he was
just like you're the [ __ ] man of the
house and like you know he was [ __ ]
holding my [ __ ] when he was doing it and
i was like
so message received you know yeah that
party up there washington yeah this was
in oklahoma yeah and uh and so then um
they pick her up and my my uh
grandparents were like i mean you gotta
send her to a place like you have no
control at this point my mom's like i
think something's gonna happen to her if
i don't do anything right so senator
this school and and uh and it was kind
of a shady thing how did you swing that
how'd your mom swing that if you don't
mind me asking what do you mean school
yeah descending away oh grandparents
okay so they stopped dancing i mean it
was probably who knows i don't know
maybe it was a tuition and 20 grand for
a year probably probably more than that
i don't know uh but a total shame i mean
paris hilton kind of outlines it in this
documentary about how abusive these
places like they [ __ ] with you they kind
of get you in and when you go to visit
they're just like what's going on hey
adam dude you want some beef stroganoff
dude you want to play some some
basketball i've heard about it's not
basket shots it's basketball we're
having a good time here no when you
leave and when we dropped her off it was
like
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] your daddy i
mean these people like lay in on them
she came back more [ __ ] up than than
she was when she went there jesus um so
that like added to the dynamic of like
living in this [ __ ] with her and and
being [ __ ] like cougar for cocoa
puffs and trying to adjust and and get
back uh to normalcy and then mom's still
trying to figure it all out and and and
now you're dealing with the animosity of
like sis being like you [ __ ] drop me
off and like of course
yeah sure and she's already you know um
you know and then when you have dad
bouncing and then your mom does that
yeah that's a i mean we've just kind of
probably gotten to a point in life where
like there's maybe a little bit of like
forgiveness that's happening really is
this supposed to get this real bad no
this is great
i love this i'm always like how much to
it's trash but i love it
i gotta say that i'm gonna paint the
picture the burrito's making a lot more
sense
oh yeah dude
you're dealing with a fat kid that never
left
i pictured you guys like a family
portrait everyone's wearing white on the
beach i was thinking like fly fishing
yeah are you saying that for the joker
for real no being
serious from a little bit of kids oh man
no way dude paid off my college loans
maybe two years ago really oh yeah
where'd you go to school went to usc for
acting school you did yeah but that's
pretty good so i auditioned for the
school to get in and um
and uh you know my sats were dog [ __ ]
what'd you get this is big on the show
11 10. that's pretty good i mean you're
a [ __ ] genius the mean the mean
second highest in the room hilarious the
mean age or average coming into my
freshman class was like 15 70 or 80.
smart kids [ __ ] yeah it's sc man and
like these uh so so they were like i had
extracurricular stuff my gpa was pretty
good you know i tried to ride the jew
thing to as far as like diversity
i mean when i when i bagged
[Laughter]
always try to look like
[Laughter]
always trying to make comments about how
i just got back from a bris
yeah i was just giving a snippet you
know you guys know moyle's guys this
guy's a jewish guy huh that's what
jewish guys say ah the traffic yeah
that's right you wouldn't believe it
i'm adam ray and this is macbeth
how all occasions do inform against me
you know what commercial i love hobbies
we've got the meats
um
so uh so
so um are you full jewish hundred
percent yeah yeah food everything i mean
the moms uh do it we did both for a
little bit uh i guess when my folks were
together christmas and hanukkah and then
just straight hanukkah but um
uh yeah so so um
you know even when i bagged groceries at
albertsons it was like uh you know when
i would get tan like old ladies thought
i were i was like cuban and [ __ ] so even
at one point the guy was asking me
because he was like trying to find the
admissions guy he's like trying to find
other ways to try to like get me in
because he's like [ __ ] i don't want the
sats to really be a determining factor
here because uh you seem like you'd be
you know be a great fit and and then
they suggested audition for the acting
school because they were like if you get
into the acting school if they take you
the school has to take you nice because
i wanted to minor in like acting and
then have room to take
look at all these cool classes there was
like beatles history and i want to take
film class i want to take business
classes i want to minor in something if
you're in the bfa acting program that's
all you have your schedule laid out nine
to six you have you know better teachers
you have class shows you're truly going
for it but at that point too i was just
like i don't know if i want to do acting
i want to do it maybe is for fun but i
don't know if i want to make it my my
soul uh you know focus so then um i
auditioned and got in and then they were
like and by the way i was
i went down there was a kid who was on
the school paper uh uh with me which by
the way i got kicked off of because i
wrote some article where i was like
cursing in it i was like about the the
money that like baseball players make i
was like can you be [ __ ] a-rod and
the woman runs the paper was like they
printed that by the way like they
printed your [ __ ] f-bombs in the
paper it was high school yeah and i was
like i was fired up it's like you're
done i was like all right
and so uh that's crazy so then me and my
buddy ran the high school news program
instead where you could like that nobody
was really like when we took it over the
scene
show like a chat like so my sophomore
year was like a 10 minute the seniors
were live with adam
it was awesome it was oh man if we could
go back and really push the envelope
our sophomore heroes when they start
airing every morning before class like
10 minutes of these seniors who just
thought they were funny they'd be uh you
know one of the the star basketball
players like and now with the weather
it's yousef reefy offshore and then
you'd be like it's sunny outside and
then somebody would pour water on his
head he's like oh [ __ ] maybe there's
rain too back to you guys in the studio
and we was like is this comedy
and so then my buddy and i took it over
sophomore year and by our senior year it
was a like a 20-minute sketch show so it
was like that somehow and at the end we
would scroll the announcements like
there's a dance there's a blah blah blah
yeah there's a what sweep suite coming
up we gotta [ __ ] clean up
tide's gonna rebuy
johnson and johnson's on the horn they
were a big hit for us yeah trying to get
tom cruise in here
could do the pledge of allegiance
brad pitt's plugging a movie maybe we
can get him oh yeah dude
uh so so we uh so we were uh jamming
away on that and and uh oh what was i
saying with the albertsons thing oh yeah
so so the diversity thing so so i was
just trying to like push that but i went
to l.a to stay with a buddy from the
paper who was in a frat at usc and he
was like stay with me to before the
night before you auditioned for for the
school
and i'm just thinking like cool a place
to crash i'm not thinking about the fact
that i'm staying in a frat
on like a thursday my audition was a
friday thursday's like probably the
bigger that's the biggest that's the
best part and frat road sc
uh is just bonkers dude i mean it's
truly just a row of [ __ ] madness i
mean i ended up being in the jew for at
a pie and one night went to a uh a a an
exchange with a sorority fraternity
called saving lives that was the theme
where and i dressed up as batman
and i passed that was the first and
probably one of three times i've ever
blacked out and was carried down the row
by a couple football players and my
buddy like very jerry maguire cuba
gooding jr was like dude you got to try
to wake up and see this as it was
carrying me down because i guess it was
like a packed row and everyone was like
applauding and screaming because they
see batman being carried down the
[ __ ] road and he was like bro you got
to wake up and i was like what he's like
look dude they're going nuts and i
remember just like opening my eyes
seeing people going batman
so uh so then i'm uh
you know uh i'm auditioning for for the
the school and that night before he's
like you know we're having a big party
tonight i was like cool i was like i'm
probably gonna just like stay in the
room go over my [ __ ] cut two
i mean first time i took bong rips and
that'll do it and dude and then drinking
and then there's like this perpendicular
to the frat row is a row of like fast
food that is just everything it's like
the vegas of fast food name a place
that's there subway tommy burger
chipotle [ __ ] del taco taco bell
mcdonald's i mean a whole strip of it
in my stoney baloney mind i go i'm gonna
go to every place and get one thing so i
went to mickey d's i to fry i went to
subway i got a cookie i went to [ __ ]
and i went down the whole thing came
back threw it all up um [ __ ] smoked
more stayed up to like five
passed out i think on the front steps or
the lawn or some [ __ ] woke up my
audition was at 11 showered was just
like what the [ __ ] like so upset at
myself like why did you do that you suck
you know gave in to peer pressure um
which you know i mean it was so easy my
my buddy was just like you know you
should come out and have a couple drinks
and i was like nah man i just i really
gotta go over my [ __ ] and he was like or
a quick bong rip i was like i'll do that
yeah for sure yeah who are you
auditioning with uh a couple monologues
i've been working on with some you know
local seattle acting teachers from mrs
doubtfire
remember the final scene of air bud
golden retriever
so i played the dog and uh there's no
dialogue and i thought it was genius
i asked the guy to throw a frisbee in my
mouth
and uh no it was a couple monologues a
dramatic and a comedic one and i
remember just being so sick that i was
like i don't honestly give a [ __ ] what
happens and i think that helped yeah
enough yeah and i got in and so then
they took me and then the school had to
take me uh but then i mean grants loans
you got the single money uh a single
mother like uh you know we feel bad for
you cash nice um and then uh and then
loans which were which were kind of a
[ __ ] and then a little bit of financial
um like a scholarship for just uh for
some academic stuff but for those long
rips that you did yeah yeah kids are
right
but yeah so thank god for that you know
what was the uh what was the number on
the bar mitzvah what'd you pull
oh dude it was probably
five ten i mean back then two this is
what 95
so
i probably the biggest
check i got was mate was probably some
hundreds right okay and then cash and
then a lot of i remember two seeing like
certain people like buddies with the
sports courts and seeing like a 20 in
the card being like yeah what the [ __ ]
and then one kid gave me a hakeem elijah
on jersey and i was like this is cool i
did ask for cash but you know this is a
nice consolation
i love the dream you know and uh
and then probably
grand total probably close to like five
grand probably that's pretty good yeah i
think for a sixth grader yeah that's
pretty good yeah and that's why i bought
the super nintendo right after that
really saw that going the other way
talking about being on the wrong side of
history and that's when i bought my [ __ ]
swing you know
i put it all in enron and kept it moving
i like that you pulled out 95 she's like
five grand but with inflation that's
like 10 10 that's like three bitcoin
nowadays
it's eight million dollars
oh yeah also a.e pie i went to temple
university and they had their uh slogan
was we put the brew in hebrew which i
thought was
some of the best marketing for a frat
ever brilliant yeah
i'll never forget that dude they called
us a high because i mean we there so
many people smoked so much pot i mean it
was we had a five foot bong
uh jesus just got ripped by this kid
named david spiegel uh jew uh
steven rabinowicz yeah all the time i
think he now works uh for
for
[Laughter]
uh dad was a doctor that was a um big
cardiovascular surgeon just retired
actually last year uh wow what 50 i
guess yeah wait so he did good he was
crushing it yeah and then um
how was he with uh well so i ended up
blue i mean ended up losing his license
before prescribing antidepressants to
his um secretary to like give to him
like really like i mean yeah i guess an
ethically [ __ ] up but but i mean he
was such a good doctor open heart
surgeries on the reg and uh
yeah he gave
his yeah because you i don't think you
could be on that stuff or maybe said yes
antidepressants uh you couldn't
i was just
i don't even know why not if you're
procedure if you're doing procedures
maybe not yeah
i don't know the true um you know uh i'd
rather have the doctor calm down and be
[ __ ] nervous one thousand percent uh
take a couple zany bars make sure you
got your head on straight oh he took my
heart's open right yeah you need a
school bus to get your head on right oh
i've heard stories of like some of these
guys like you know pulling these
all-nighters in like 40-hour surgeries
like falling asleep at the [ __ ] weather
cutting so it's like yeah hey man put
them on whatever they need yeah what do
the job um but that uh so that kind of
cut the supply chain off and then made
things extra tough and then they and
then he was just up [ __ ] creek without a
paddle for for i mean has always been
since so um so did he ever get his
license back
yeah in certain spots but um
uh yeah and was able to to start working
again and then move to
sounds like he got real with his family
so he went to az to kind of work for a
little bit then move to an island called
midway island in the uh which is like
you know halfway to i think maybe
between guam and hawaii wait what what's
up midway there's like 100
took place that was where one of the
biggest battles of world war ii yeah did
you say mash yeah yeah
is that where they filmed no not at all
dude they filmed it in burbank what are
you talking about this is what i find i
don't think they filmed it there if this
is where i find out that none of the the
filipinos on that island told me that i
was [ __ ] walking around where alan
alda was taking
and that's not the first time i've said
that
uh yeah so then he went to midway then
went to kwajalein which is another
island deep in the the [ __ ] middle of
the ocean damn that's [ __ ] and then
taos new mexico and then uh sounds like
a tax shelter in nevada
they're real loose out there in guam
that's technically a territory take all
the anti-depressants you want doesn't
matter load this guy up those are seeing
his prescriptions there are these things
called goony birds don't cancel me and
they uh no these giant ass birds um uh
called gooney birds
midway i don't even like little birds
you land and they were like giant
pelican flamingo things that literally
were like everywhere like you couldn't
walk without [ __ ] i mean it looked
like the scene from uh from hitchcock's
birds like where you're just like i'm
gonna [ __ ] get eaten by these uh
these never-ending story uh you know
tasmanian devil things and they're just
flying around squawking and cocking at
you and um and it was cool to visit
played a lot of basketball uh how old
are you when this is going on when he
moves out to midway so that was probably
funny that's crazy that's an insane
statement yeah i thought that was just
like a reality
yeah no they had a handful of uh america
maybe 30 americans out there and then he
was one of the doctors out there and
they would do a lot of stuff and then
send people to the big island if they
really needed it and kwajalein was more
uh like 2 500 americans were they had
middle school high school um you know
elementary school so my half brothers
were out there and um and that was cool
to to visit and um how often would you
go out there i went out there maybe
twice and how old were you starting to
ask high school so when he was in midway
that was sophomore year and then um
and then uh kwajalein was um was a
junior i actually went on the show blind
date twice as a joke i wore wigs to try
to [ __ ] with these girls and one was
awesome the girl got black out drunk and
fell out of the van and it was on ease
101 dating moments where we're at a bar
and she slips and falls and i just go
whoa as she falls and they like put that
on the [ __ ] and i was like could you
pick a better moment where i'm a little
more supportive instead of just watching
her fall wait blind are we jumping
around here with roger lodge yeah wait
yeah that was the one where you would
like you would like go like do like a
boxing class and then like yeah and
there'd be the thumb bubbles like these
guys you're really about to take the
real punch man some of those would get
hot and some of those would get hot so i
wanted i wanted to get to the hot tub so
i brought that hot tub man
i was like a 12 year old if they ended
up in that hot tub my pants were coming
off
dude one thousand percent it was just
seeing his pornhub back then it was
must-see i would have jerked off to you
a thousand percent you did uh and uh
right now
dude it was like because they would show
it wasn't just like you'd see them like
start to inching and kiss and then
they'd cut away or like close the door
to the house it's like they'd show them
like sloppy making there was like a
heavy pen a minute and a half yeah the
guy be touching her ted it was a it was
a lot let's talk about the good folks
over there black buffalo baby if you're
21 and over and you dip or chew tobacco
pouches are long cut it don't matter you
have to try this tobacco alternative
black buffalo
it's everything you love about dipping
including the pharmaceutical grade
nicotine just without the actual tobacco
leaf or stem it's literally made from
edible green leaves and food grade
ingredients with the same flavors
textures aroma pack nicotine as
traditional tobacco products with no
compromise required guys at some point
you're going to get out you're going to
have to get off the
tobacco it's tough or at least cut back
a little bit and back black buffalo is
here to help you i know a lot of you
bozos out there are smoking bernies
chewing dipping the whole nine yards you
gotta get off and the best part about
this black buffalo baby
born in the usa born in the midwest
raised in the south that's some good old
boys for you black buffalo proudly
manufactures their products here in the
u.s of a homegrown baby
they were they sent us some of it i
dabble
you got to check it out if you want to
get off the tobacco which you should do
um so right now uh for listeners of ru
garbage you'll get 25 off your first
order with promo code garbage at
checkout go to blackbuffalo.com
use promo code garbage 25 off your first
order that's 25 boncos adding 10 percent
adding 15 at any 20s 25 that's a quarter
of money baby
um one more time go to blackbuffalo.com
promo code garbage for 25 off your first
order and then we gotta say warning this
product contains nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical shout out to the good
folks at mint mobile baby i'm a big mint
mobile guy as you know my wife uses it
uh and this holiday season it's the best
deal you can get in wireless
and it can only be found at mint mobile
right now when you switch to mint mobile
and buy any three month plan you'll get
three months free three months free what
are we doing here they're giving away to
store as the first company to sell
premium wireless services online only
mobile lets you
order from your home and save a ton with
phone plans starting at just 15 bucks a
month and it is literally 15 bucks a
month there's no hidden fees there's no
nothing
like i said my wife's been using it for
years she signed up on it and now
there's no point to ever join a big
network it's fantastic the the
that's the best offer of the year for a
limited time by any three month plan get
three months for free by going online
limiting the traditional cost of retail
the cut out the middle man that's that's
what good business does they cut out the
middleman only bozos use middlemen all
right all plans come with unlimited talk
and text high speed data delivered on
nation on the nation's largest 5g
network use our use your own phone with
any mint mobile plan
and your and the same phone number along
with your existing contacts switch to
mint mobile and get premium wireless
service starting at just 15 bucks a
month
that's like 10 less than what most of
you bozos are paying for a limited time
only by any three month plan and get
three months for free by going to
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com garbage cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com garbage do it now back to
the show
did you make out on the show so i tried
to i brought the batman suit because in
my head it's a joke oh my god so she
rips my weight i'll steal the deal
i wasn't trying to find love [ __ ] up i
brought to batman hey you want to kiss a
virgin it was all a big goof
i'd gotten one hand job to this point
yeah i'm talking about double dipping
your greatest moment so my whole
they carry me down frat row in this
thing you're gonna love this one yeah
yeah yeah
oh yeah
yeah yeah well because in my head i go i
as a joke i go i want to get to the hot
tub so that there's a wide shot of me in
the batman suit and then she's sitting
across the room
what's the boom situation what's the jib
situation over here and then i go
they'll cut to me and then i'll go
batman suit they said bring a bathing
suit not batman suit that's a pretty
good bit i'll give it that's what i
wanted to do and then uh but we didn't
make it that far because she fell out of
the uh the car and they sent her home
she was from chico uh california which
is she went to chico state which is a
real we took like we did body shots i
did uh they were like so you're a jewish
guy right and i was like yeah there's
probably a better way you can say that
and so like we're gonna do a hebrew
lesson in the park and drink mana
shepherd's wine so she's never had that
so we do that and then we're taking i
mean triple shots of tequila at like the
lunch portion so she's hammered
and then that's why she fell out of the
[ __ ] van and then that was a wrap and
i was like so we're not going to the hot
tub and then she goes like that to me as
she's like puking and they added a gun
sound effect
i was like like that's not a gun and so
um and so uh then the second time i went
on this girl was uh i'm talking about my
dad being uh
is this when you're at usc college yeah
yeah okay and i'm talking about my dad
living on cuadro that was the whole
point of this and the girl like was such
a prude and she was like she's like you
just make up islands where your dad
lives
no it's a real place you can look it up
she's like yeah i know i think you're
lying i go you think i would make up an
island that my dad lives on i go i gave
you a little bit of the backstory about
how my folks put and he moved with his
new family to this is a lot of research
for me to do like how much do you think
i really want to impress you you already
said you don't drink and you don't like
spaghettios like you're o for two as far
as i'm concerned listen lady i got
spider-man outfit under my shirt what
are we doing
[Laughter]
we're running out of film we only got
one shot at this and the sun's going
down yeah yeah we got one roger lodge
outtake in the can if this doesn't go
let's go adam ray coming in here [ __ ]
stunning us i mean so so then uh so then
yeah went out to visit dad and then so
he moved all over laughlin nevada then
um a couple places in oregon and now
he's in salem oregon but just retired
but but was crushing it when he was in
the heyday of it i mean truly and uh son
of a doctor yeah but but then also i
mean again like going back to just like
living when my folks were together i
don't remember
like you know it's not like we did crazy
trips or anything like that so it's like
where was that money going you know or
or but but you know historically my my
my pops is uh you know probably not been
the best with with handling all that but
um
but yeah so it was uh
it wasn't too
uh
going from that to them being with mom
like was
you know things were dicier and just
more like [ __ ] we can't do as much
and you gotta like watch things more but
it didn't feel like that crazy of a
thing because before wasn't like a
lavish yeah right i wasn't living dr kid
money if that makes sense when you're a
little kid you don't really really know
yeah do totally it's like you get a
playmobil [ __ ] pirate ship you're
like that's 14 bucks i think most people
could [ __ ] pick that up at the store
you know and so you said your mom's
remarried now you're married now settled
down settled i mean she's good she's
happy she's you know that she had that
ten years of of trying to figure out
with uh glass blowers and basket shot
throwers and how about the sis other
than that sis remarried married dirty
and and um uh finally got her [ __ ]
doing okay yeah doing doing okay i mean
yeah there's every family's you know as
you just get on you go man there's just
like no
nobody is immune to
the family drama the [ __ ] no no
one's perfect i mean it's like you know
and i feel like i've i've um
not maybe been the glue to the fan but
definitely tried sounds like a little
bit trying to keep my own [ __ ] at bay
and never bring that to the table
because everyone i feel like is just
dealing with more stuff and i'm like i'm
kind of getting to do what i want
and there's i mean you know you guys
know it's like we have in the daily
grind of all this there's so much stress
and uh stress and pressure and and
things that can get you down and get you
up and but uh but i still feel like it's
i have less to complain about but yeah
yeah of course i mean i i i give you
credit for that because it does sound
like you did that i mean the last thing
your mom [ __ ] needed was you walking
around in a batman suit yeah dude so
look at her stealing her other minivan
if that was the last time i was on tv
she probably would have killed herself
ah all right let's get into some [ __ ]
uh are you garbage okay news here yeah
um
i mean the writing's on the wall though
but yeah man what a tale
what was
nobody lives in the original house that
you grew up in right uh no people do now
yeah like yeah not your family not my
family yeah so what was that what was
the name of that street because you
mentioned cul-de-sac oh yeah which is
pretty classy i'm a cul-de-sac kid
myself i love them dude yeah the amount
of like from your baseball i mean like
was you know and um
uh you don't even have to look both ways
when you cross the street so what was
the name of that street
i want to say 35th place maybe and then
ballinger way was where i lived at the
uh at the end that's pretty good
ballinger that was like a long away is
really good is it okay yeah all right
but i mean you know working at the uh
the albertsons grocery store in high
school i mean it's like again you saw
that's where you got to see like people
coming in late night the [ __ ] skeezy
shady people buying like just peanut
butter and lube being like hey man you
know you guys still got diet cashews
you're like that's not a real food
it's good to see you again thomas you
know giant catch you know and then and
then you get the people coming in buying
you know 500 a day worth of groceries
just the moms that are like you know
just making the best lunches and and you
know just you know having affairs and
just you know all sorts of lunchables
for breakfast real classy oh yeah dude
definitely pulled some of that i mean
yeah the the uh
the uh town center is where that was but
again that's where you got to see all
the different level uh levels everybody
there was money that was sure coming
through um was albertsons where your
mother shopped yeah growing up so i
so she uh she was like look i'm gonna
help you get like a
um
uh a car and uh but you gotta pay for
the gas and the insurance and so we got
something for about 800-900 bucks and um
and then uh real piece of [ __ ] little
chevy spectrum that was like
i mean four seats but like we packed in
i was one of the first kids to drive and
one summer we packed in probably 12 kids
from the basketball courts we played at
in the summer down to like where the
lake was
and the car was just like scratching on
the ground on ballinger way we were all
just laughing no it was just a little
four seat um it wasn't a hatchback no
because i had a chevy spectrum hatchback
did you really [ __ ] stick my brother
[ __ ] love my brother wasn't a great
car
oh yeah [ __ ] zipping stick too huh oh
yeah i was always real impressed by
those kids i'm surprised you didn't
that's very trashy kid thing to drive
stick oh yeah i thought you were who's
got automatic money
for real yeah stickers i thought stick
just was like i don't know it was cooler
it was just sticks are cheaper oh really
yeah manual transmissions much more
knowledge
especially back then yeah i mean there
were no windows on my car but yeah
one door and for the record foley's
scraped on the ground too yeah
that's just me in there yeah yeah uh so
so um
so yeah so that uh so then so then got
albertsons was the job to kind of pay
for all that stuff and uh which sucked
too because i'm the only kid working
during the summer all my friends are
coming in and the albertsons was at this
like town center across the street from
the lake so they're all coming in
the girl it's like fresh bikinis
[ __ ] smooshing people's eggs and [ __ ]
oh dude it was the one hey ray make sure
you cut my crust i remember a girl came
in um or was it siobhan or maybe ellen
right just one of these girls let's go
with siobhan let's go siobhan yeah she's
just crushing the game and she's like
and sees me and then does a wave and
then comes over and it's like do you
know where like they keep the you know
just some item that was like rubbing at
my face that i couldn't like the tanning
layer was like the titty like i need to
like i mean someone's i need somebody to
like i wish you could do it but you're
putting the [ __ ] bagel bites on top
of the toaster strudel i want to get
your lunch meat stink
nice apron at them
you're like daniel russo oh yeah i would
always go out to collect carts so that i
could just like get out and try to like
you know meet up with some of my buds
and and get the the scoop on what was
happening like who's who's over there
and they're like oh do you gotta can you
just leave no man i gotta pay for my
spectrum man
how we're gonna get from the basketball
court to the late
next week well look at you now baby yeah
man look at you now you're doing okay
probably have three spectrums if you
want
go back there and buy that
albert is a top notch i used to be an
albertson's employee myself top-notch
operation
yeah they bought acme acme's out here
you know on the east coast and
albertsons bought acne good man they
always had like good um
you know like the potato style there was
a girl that worked behind the service
deli was like the first time i remember
like
getting like a hookup and also hooked up
with the girl that was in the service
deli and she was like five years older
than me i think i was 17 she was 22
maybe even 25. and she went to date and
i was like i'm [ __ ] 17 and then she
never gave me [ __ ] she never i
remember one time we had like a weird
text exchange and then i walked up to
the on my break and i was like hey you
might have guessed something is out and
she was like it's gonna be a minute and
i was like oh take a number wait did you
already go on a date
no we didn't we just had hooked up a
handful of times and then she kind of
wanted to like date and i was like i
like i know nothing about i i still get
tied down right now i'm driving a
spectrum
i can't get tied down for sure it's the
only place i get my potato salad honey
a lot of grocery stores in this
tri-state area
let a player play you know what i mean
stop putting raisins in the coleslaw
maybe we'll talk
i should cut you off huh yeah yeah i saw
you kind of shortchanged me on those
jojos huh you know what jojo's alright
the little potato uh little potato um uh
[ __ ] it so uh
no but you're trash man
let me get a bag of jojo's and uh what's
that mouth dog
oh my god yeah so she's still there but
no she uh definitely not as attractive
as you remember that was the end of that
man i think she dated a military guy and
um i remember like
kept tabs on her huh
what's her instagram handle
[Laughter]
get the guy some goddamn potato salad
that's beautiful too good good i've been
told that story in a long time
good i felt good to get that off my
chest there you go
hold that one start crying
oh my god
all right i got one have you ever
crashed someone else's car
oh
um
yeah um i mean
just i
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
uh
you guys filming this yeah
you guys aren't recording i think really
just i mean um
i mean my fiance's right now i just hers
just got kind of not totaled but banged
up pretty hard just on our street but i
mean it was totally not uh my fault but
um person just wasn't looking slammed
right into the driver's side oh damn um
nah i mean it's a real great story not i
mean
again probably mom's car [ __ ] up a few
times but everybody crashes their mom's
awesome yeah you have to it's a rite of
passage also yeah i it was also oh yeah
when i when my mom's car got uh jacked
up the van it was um
uh coming back from a uh dave matthews
band concert oh that'll do it and uh and
uh she wasn't with you was she no i was
driving my buddies back here
fell asleep at the wheel and uh you did
yeah and i remember like falling asleep
like this and then like in like you know
we we didn't like sleep that last night
and it's like you party all night and
then you the sun's up at like four
everyone camps out at the gorge which is
like an unbelievable venue in washington
state and it's where they close their
shows at i mean tom petty should go
there all the time the big festivals rap
festivals reggae festivals it's like
the the amphitheaters on the edge of
this canyon with the columbia river
behind it you camp out it's [ __ ]
incredible it's like three hours it
really is all over the place with the
lake and the albertsons and then there's
a lot going on
i'm trying to i know we only got like
what we got like two i don't know how
much whatever time no it's you're paying
nothing
for the corporate party it's a big mix
yeah so so uh so we're driving back and
i didn't sleep because i'd uh you know
those dave matthews bands concert uh
concerts you're walking around
everyone's playing songs everyone's like
dude man saratoga 98 man that version of
lion our graves
who's maybe the best man because there's
like carter was ripping it on the drums
and everyone's just like feeling good he
did a bunch of drugs what's that he did
a bunch of drugs i did yeah and i think
i didn't think you were drinking protein
[ __ ] tonight
are you trying to explain it like you're
like so they're hanging out i finished
my third year
drive them back we get it
and so we've been doing a concert before
not a day matthew's been concert though
and so uh so uh so i eat the uh bunch of
edibles
and my buddies leave my buddies leave i
was with probably three buds and i wake
up there's like two hours where
everyone's out like probably four to
maybe six where it's still dark and it's
just [ __ ] quiet there's maybe a
couple people up you still can hear
music faintly and uh and i wake up at
this person's camp thing and it's it's a
[ __ ] big campground
and you you come in the first day of
three days friday or something you park
and then you set up shop and
and i didn't know where the [ __ ] i was
and i wake up i'm so disoriented like
truly and very high and just and now i
go into panic mode because i'm like
there's no way i'm gonna find
cell's dead like there's no way so i
walk for no joke a little under two
hours all over the campground finally
see my buddies
uh [ __ ] see the thing i start running
i go wake the [ __ ] up i start kicking
them all in their sleeping bags they
immediately start laughing one of my
buddies was getting a hand job during as
i was kicking them uh because he's like
all over again
get to batman and then uh and then i get
it and we wake up that morning we drive
back and uh yeah so i mean i was uh half
asleep and i i i you know jostled the
car once and i look in the rearview
mirror because everyone else was
sleeping and i see one of my buddies go
and then he wakes up and he just goes
did you just fall asleep and i was like
no yeah and they kept driving that
philosophy again and then just like
scraped alongside a car like on the
freeway
crazy
yeah and i have to tell about it
ever wear a puka shell necklace
uh
yes when i was on uh uh midway island
for sure you know what i'm saying when i
was out there on the and quad way
passport trying to blend in
[Laughter]
um can you name the guys from pawn stars
oh
no oh that's a good sign good there you
go no
have you had a slider in the last 365
days
oh yeah okay love those
mickey mouse watch you ever wear one
nobody had a dick tracy watch
i remember a joke
like as a kid
that was a great question
is this a bit again a bit like for real
man like you wanted that
i mean were you a little like you asked
someone to get you that it was like
anything else yeah it was like because
remember dick tracy had that thing where
he would like did it come with halfway
you know madonna is showing her put you
know was it a happy meal thing no it was
like a um
were you an adult when you bought it no
this was a kid probably okay all right
that's okay no mickey mouse watch that's
probably but i had a i mean
i just posted recently a pic of us at
disneyland my mom took sis and i i think
shortly after they split to kind of like
hey we'll go to disneyland and that'll
fix everything and i had a uh a
fanny pack and a michael jordan shirt
and like [ __ ] some nike like it was a
it was a mess but a disneyland hat like
a goofy sweatshirt and like goofy i mean
it was
[ __ ] dude it was a bad stuff
i'll give you that all right it's all
right yeah i'm like i'm not gonna
go to the bus for that when was the last
time you did karaoke
oh i love karaoke
what do you have a go-to song
um
once you got one song and you're closing
out the night
everyone's pumping you come on get up
get up i don't do you gotta [ __ ]
what's up you're right i mean bohemian
rhapsody i'll do the whole thing and
i'll go freely oh yeah i did it i
studied abroad in london and there was a
madame tussauds wax museum and um and at
the end of it uh my buddies where i was
in the program with we went got a little
stoney baloney walked through this at
the end there's a huge
like a huge open area like you know
whole through the museum is pretty like
close quarters but there's a huge like
cafe and there's a big stage and they
have uh you know um british idol
whatever they have simon uh and another
judge and then an open space for for
somebody to come sit and then somebody
hosting so you can be on you know
british idol whatever and it's basically
karaoke in this big open
area at the end of the tour and so um i
was like i'm gonna go up there and
and uh and sing a song and now all the
songs by the way are maxed out like 30
to 40 seconds so i told a guy i was like
hey you got bohemian rhapsody and he was
like yeah he's like but that song's like
19 minutes i go
start slow come in heavy
watch me for the changes and try to keep
up will you
we're going to drop it down to the key
of c blow these brit's hairs back
i want that fake simon to come to life
and start applauding
and so uh i do the whole thing dude and
i like it was a wireless mic like i was
on tables i went to the headset i mean
i'm in acting school so i'm just full on
yeah yeah and i'm like dude i this place
was so no one's paying attention to it
by the end of it dude
everyone's watching people are [ __ ]
applauding getting into it i [ __ ] was
like you know pulling people up on the
tables [ __ ] singing like giving to
the mic like going like that and and um
you melted all the wax figures that was
so hot
kid's throwing heat up here yeah yeah uh
yeah fake betty white came to life
and so uh
you're dancing with her
so that's a go to uh also any i mean any
90s uh you know r b thing if i'm real
[ __ ] up or um or uh billy oceans get
out of my dreams get into my car you're
speaking
okay i love the billions i love karaoke
anywhere i mean dude uh have you ever
ran into one of those rooms and done
like a party oh yeah
those rooms creak me there's no windows
it's weird in there yeah it's awesome
like the worst casino yeah i don't was
hoping for adam devine on we did a
little australia tour and then uh japan
uh a big troops thing and we went to
some dive bar and did uh
him and i were just so hammered and did
a uh duet of uh creeds take me higher
and like sounds like a good time god
gotta be honest and got a lot of people
involved and it was like
it was like sat like
it was sad how into it everyone was you
know what i'm saying we're like i'm even
looking over seeing a couple like being
like you know it was like somebody
proposes
it's the best night of my life there's a
flyover at the end of it the blue angels
show up
crocs wear them
[ __ ] no okay hard pass hmm have you ever
started the wave at a sporting event oh
all the time that's a seattle staple i
remember when i was first time i went to
fenway uh uh in boston um for like some
choir orchestra trip when we went to a
red sox game and i tried to start the
wave and somebody goes shut the [ __ ]
down
and i was like it's a seattle wave he
goes [ __ ] you nobody gives a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you no mom i agree with that guy yeah
i want to go on record i'm friends with
that guy yeah yeah
but that's that's a big seattle i was
you know a blind date fan yeah
season 9.
you have a [ __ ] celebrity i know
roger lodge man take it
[Music]
oh you can oh you easy him prove it
growing up did the refrigerator that you
had in your house was it side by side
uh freezer on the top
oh yeah it was a a fridge and then
freezer on the side did you have the did
you have the water in the ice
the chilled water in the ice machine
no okay yeah
not not till maybe
growing up no and then high school yeah
all right um
anyone in your family really into harry
potter
did you read all the books no i did a
girl in high school that was really into
it and always and was really always
definitely bummed out that i was like
couldn't get on board the fantasy stuff
even i've never i've seen 20 minutes of
the first lord of the rings
uh game of thrones i mean i know there's
a lot of butts and dragons right mm-hmm
i love one of the reasons the harry
potter that i is i can't get my head
around is that adults
were reading
a 1200 page book about
children's fantasy that's what always
freaked me out oh yeah
yeah it's um that's what i thought was
trash a thousand percent i was nine of
them twilight even
ah that would take me eight years to
read that it seems like a lot of your
life to dedicate to something that
doesn't matter
yeah sorry sorry everyone who loves that
stuff yeah we just shat on most of our
fan base i hope he cut that
they tried i just couldn't do it if i
had to pick i mean the harry potter
rider universal is pretty cool i mean if
you like motion scenes i love the movies
don't get me wrong i'm a dumbledore fan
oh yeah i just don't know how anybody
[ __ ] read those things yeah i don't
know yes nerds
you're a harry potter are you a harry
potter guy t-bone dog i waited on my
front porch for fedex to deliver the
fourth one too
just two weeks
you're ago fired after this wow
and you sat there and you read it oh
yeah how old were you oh eleven oh okay
yeah listen as a kid that's what i'm
saying were you pumped like when you
read that fourth one you're like it's
just as good as the third one did you
leave your head gear in or what did you
do have you beat yourself up after you
yeah i gave myself a wedgie i closed it
and i was like i can't believe i have to
wait two more years for the next one i
was legit sad
she did that was smart she probably had
them all ready to go
you guys are younger than me i forget if
you were a kid and you were into it i
thought that that's great yeah eleven
yeah oh yeah i mean now you're reading a
thousand pages a book that's
unbelievable but my problem is is like
my generation they were reading it too
it's like you're 31 yeah yeah what are
you doing now how do you feel about with
comics because like i so i when my first
job out of uh uh college was a tour
guide on the tram at universal studios
and then i played wolverine for a couple
years and the other guys that were
marvel comic characters that's pretty
sweet it was cool it was it was like 23
an hour and the tour guiding was like 8
15 hours did you take the suit home at
you no i didn't that would have been
hard but i did get i mean there was i
mean
there's just stories for days on that
too but you hook up with any other cast
members yeah i mean it's any work job
yeah man
beetlejuice shrek
the second the the backup blues brother
john goodman's character
what the [ __ ] john goodman
i brought character to talk to a lot of
celebs man i mean dude i remember it
full wolverine garb was just like just
doing this going paycheck to greg maddox
and i was like dude i'm a huge fan he
was like what
from the braves yeah
[Laughter]
i was also a new york cop and uh who
like wasn't from anything you're walking
there there's like a special event in
real life like i thought you weren't i
was like this guy was on the job
well yeah you know i had to protect uh
you know so you worked at university
from getting accosted by door of the
explorer it was a lot of stuff i worked
at universal studios as an actor about
eight years yeah wow yeah and um it was
i mean it was a lot of fun and a lot of
cool uh people there but yeah same also
i'm doing i'm waving this night stick
and i got this big orville redenbacher
mustache and a whistle and i blow it i
go i go hey slow down speed racer i go i
go i go they're not going to run out of
moose at vidal satsune and he just looks
at me and just goes
nice
like basically yeah i get it dude you're
an actor trying to do a bit with me like
and just i mean rip the rug out from one
of me i was just like all right you have
a good day stamos
take it easy uncle jesse
you're putting your resume back in your
you pocket your screenplay back
i guess you won't be needing this mr st
those are those people there dude
spielberg came in the park one day and
people definitely brought stuff and
we're like had it on them and this is my
point about the comics there's a lot of
the guys that were the other characters
were obsessed and they'd come in the
break room i remember the guy dressed as
beetlejuice been there for like 40 years
remember i walk in one day i'm peeling
off the sideburns and and uh and he sits
down he just takes it he goes he goes
fellas he goes take a look and he takes
it out of this like package he goes mint
condition archie or whatever [ __ ] and
they're all like holy [ __ ] and i was
like whoa what wait so what is that and
he's like i forgot
abray doesn't like comics because i just
was like yeah i was never a comic guy i
think i had a couple ninja turtle ones
but never enough to really like make it
a party but that was like because you
were probably a ninja turtle fan yeah it
wasn't like i'm a fan of comic books i'm
gonna get this this is but these are
adults still in the comics so this is
like my question like yeah
this happened in the not like growing up
the only association in the 90s with
comic books was comic book nerd like
right you were a nerd if no one and then
comic book movies came out and it's like
the coolest thing in the world my
friends are like i've been reading the
comic books the whole time like nobody
[ __ ] told me yeah like you were all
everybody was doing it in secret for a
decade yeah and now it's like the
coolest thing now it's the coolest right
and i mean now they're and now it's also
they probably have like you know a step
up as far as like knowing what stories
are coming up next i mean like somebody
told me there's like 30 marvel movies
like in the [ __ ] waiting in the wings
right [ __ ] characters you just don't
awesome you know yeah i haven't even
been introduced yet i can't [ __ ]
spark [ __ ] or something like there's
gotta be some sort of it's not my cup of
tea i can't wait for the spider-man to
come out i can't [ __ ] wait oh really
oh big spider-man guy huge [ __ ] love
it
i love it i couldn't read when i was a
kid though still can't i couldn't get
into the comics i just i couldn't damn
couldn't read my brain i mean i i could
but i was terrible at it
i didn't have enough attention to
[ __ ] get through all that stuff when
did you wait did you struggle with the
reading in class oh yeah yeah
i mean everybody did but if you truly
like i could read yeah they didn't find
i didn't i didn't get glasses until i
was in like eighth grade so that was the
problem so well
yeah that's the excuse he's using now
and then when i was in college i was
diagnosed with with like really bad add
yeah yeah i was bouncing off the [ __ ]
walls but they tried to give me ritalin
to [ __ ] uh take care of it i went up
to penn state for new year's eve and we
did a whole bottle in one night so oh my
god nick's name on that god wait was
there a moment where you read a sentence
with like out any trouble and it was
like the [ __ ] aha moment or like you
just almost started crying because
you're like holy [ __ ] i think i can read
now like was there one moment
one phrase i didn't do much reading that
weekend at penn state
like was there a moment where you i
don't know read the back of the catalog
or no that wasn't they never gave me
another bottle after it got you they
were like what where where is this and
they were like i was like in your adult
life did you read something where you go
[ __ ] i had no problems getting
through that sentence
i knew all the syllables i got the sound
i centered it out properly without
having to do it in my head probably not
yeah probably not okay yeah let's go
ahead and move on
did you guys do
in like junior high this kid's dumb
i'm not getting what i want here
would you guys have like problems
okay
i can read a script oh great yeah oh
cool so it's just certain things that
get in the way yeah yeah
all right cool
beautiful beautiful silence don't take
that out
what was the next question i forget i
have one okay you're doing well now
you're doing good you're okay right
um
when you got your first big check um did
you do anything stupid with it oh yeah
lay it on us oh man um got a um what are
we talking when are we talking
probably it was after the uh the heat
was probably like the first cool thing i
got to be a part of and and um get some
like residuals from and i think maybe it
was like a 25 000 residual check what
residual check from like the uh oh you
know all the back dvds whatever uh yeah
or it yeah um what was the initial
payment if you don't mind me asking um
not too crazy i mean it was like
i have 25 right now oh no no no no
more actually maybe maybe it was like
five a week maybe it's maybe i got maybe
close to 20 but then you take out
you know agency sure all that stuff yeah
uh but you got a residual just because
it was the first thing so there's like a
not and when you're
you know i was um i was out there for
like a couple months in boston doing it
but it was uh
um i just i was at such a beginning
stage of it to where i think they could
get away with sure last two but you got
a visual check for 25 yeah and
yeah so i mean i definitely did uh i
think i took my fam to like a um
you know uh
uh some beach house thing in in seattle
and did a whole and rented like bouncy
houses for my nieces and nephews spend
all 25. that's [ __ ] awesome a lot of
it yeah and then um uh
i bought a lot of weed like i had a uh
like a buddy that just i just bought a
lot i want i always wanted to fantasize
about like having a drawer
just full of [ __ ] weed so i probably
probably dropped a thousand bucks on
[ __ ] a lot of i like that and then
the trip and then definitely some shoes
um
and uh
that might have been it nothing that
grew in value i would assume no no i'll
just quit those
oh i went back and got another sega
saturn just to kind of relive the good
old days and see if star fox still held
up they're gonna come back i'm telling
you yeah yeah
very good
i think i just got one or two more here
yeah i think the writing's on the wall
let me ask you this real quick though
did you guys have toys or a shopping
sprees thrown in your face as a kid did
you see commercials for when a toys or a
shopping spree oh yeah is that a is that
a garbage thing to want to be
to fantasize about that or to think like
to want that i would want that because
rich kids are like i can get that yeah
now
you're gonna taunt a muppet giraffe in
my face and think that's the way i can
right like yeah i would have loved
everyone's like two minutes with a card
and you like you had it
strategized and they would like air them
live i think like in between the super
bowl well not that but it was like i
remember
we have to take a commercial break kick
it over to kitty city
presidential inauguration
caleb's got 90 seconds
the notre dame game yeah
what a rookie mistake
rookie mistakes
they take up too much space in the car
bubble go for the collectibles stevie
his parents make like four grand a year
he's so nervous goes to the bathroom to
take his [ __ ] the whole family's
future's riding on this
we were gonna sell all these items
make sure that cart's got four good
wheels oh my god that in supermarket
sweep you let me go in a supermarket i'm
cleaning up by the way diapers baby
formula turkey you commentating all by
the way father just seeing you
commentating those things they should
bring those back in half
that was amazing rookie mistake i can't
believe it
like a younger dig by towel over here
looks like someone's going straight for
the barbies am i right jenny
[Music]
[Laughter]
mom's favorite singer do you know oh
bette midler
and i uh yeah i uh yeah i i met bette
midler um at a uh holiday party and uh
that's pretty clear she's pretty pretty
drunk and went over to her and um harry
gets called that's correct and caught no
one called and she said what up to my
mom it was amazing oh really my mom says
she like wants to come back uh as bette
midler in a second life and i'm like
this is probably the second creepiest
thing you've said
but she's sure she works like that yeah
yeah she's obsessed yeah um and sinatra
okay yeah all right shout out pretty
good
um and uh the lead singer of smash mouth
that actually i actually put him over
sinatra
based on that last video that came out
you see that yeah what was it i didn't
when i came into college or like oh my
god behind a kfc taco bell it's it's
somewhere it's kind of seedy and he's
just like
it's not just belligerent like he's on
the moon yeah and he and it's the video
i think they even spliced it up to kind
of make it uh sinatra we're talking
about
fly me to the line when him dean martin
got up to him but what the [ __ ] no
there's a lead singer smash mouth just
going for it was that a it was at a it
was at a winery or like a vineyard type
thing and he was like spitting queuing
on [ __ ]
it was incoherent i think it was like i
think it just took a sip of beer and
then like spit it on a woman oh that he
did that too he did everything you don't
want to do in the mu in the rockstar
handbook i think he forgot the words to
like all-star or something it was like
bad yeah i could do that right now he's
like hey now you're a good guy
i think so
oh that glitters is the gop and they're
gonna take over
pizzagate
ladies and gentlemen mr adam ray 100
certified pacific northwest garbage yeah
kid is trash well we [ __ ] love you
that was a tail man
thank you so much for being so open and
honest about everything [ __ ]
absolutely fantastic um what do you got
coming up what do you want the folks out
there to know oh man so uh today i don't
know this drops but december uh um 10th
uh i'm on this show called crossing
swords on hulu that the robot chicken
guys created uh it's me seth green tony
hale breckenmeier uh adam powley uh
event nicole brown um loves rick and
meier yeah nicholas holt it's a filthy
medieval time show but it's all the
stop-motion robot chicken animation nice
peg people in medieval times but it's
[ __ ] super filthy it's uh south park
meets uh [ __ ] i don't know all in the
family it's uh it's a it's a awesome
show um comes out today how about today
and hulu i think all the episodes so
when the time this comes out it'll it'll
probably have a episode or two out
people could check it out yeah and then
uh season uh two of young rock um i go
back to film that in um january i'm
playing vince mcmahon on that show and
then awesome comes out of march uh 15th
and then the podcast about last night um
just had on sandra bullock and you know
yeah big fan they're the best and then
uh adamwrightcomedy.com for tour dates
check it out unbelievable what what an
episode
just at cameron comedy on all social
media patreon subscribe to the youtube
the whole nine yards thank you so much
guys we appreciate it gang we absolutely
love you and we'll see you next week